la décision ne faisait plus de doute
après le test positif au coronavirus
d'une enseignante de musique lundi 9
mars les autorités ont acté la fermeture
de huit classes à l'école élémentaire
lully vauban à versailles
la rectrice de l'académie a rencontré
les professeurs pour échanger avec eux
des mesures à prendre et de la
continuité pédagogique a assuré les
éléments de la continuité pédagogique
c'est permettre à chaque enfant pendant
les 15 jours qui sont devant nous
d'avoir accès
des contenus et à son programme donc on
fait les enseignants ici eh bien ils ont
mis en place un blog en effet
j'ai vivement conseillé aux enseignants
d'essayer la classe virtuelle la classe
virtuelle c'est un ordinateur devant soi
on a face à soi l'ensemble des élèves
lesquels peuvent lever la main à
intervenir
on a un tableau sur lequel on peut
écrire et donc être dans une
configuration de classe tout à fait tout
à fait normal suite au confinement de
l'enseignante qui a contracté le
qu'ovide 19 le corps enseignant a de
suite réagi en créant un blog pour
fournir du travail aux élèves isolé ça
du coup les enseignants vont pouvoir
déposer du contenu pédagogique savoir
des extraits de manuel qu'ils ont pu
scanner ou pris en photo des exercices à
faire en plus des vidéos à regarder sur
différents sites notamment en anglais
puis d'autres choses en fonction de leur
projet de classe les parents d'élèves
confiné ont pu trouver sur le site de
l'école le lien du blog celui classe sur
18 ont été fermées à l'école lully
vauban le directeur a reçu dans la
matinée les parents inquiets certains
sont inquiets que sa façon dans la
compréhension pourquoi telle classe evra
c'est pourquoi pas telle autre m'a alors
expliqué que c'étaient les classes qui
avaient été en contact avec
l'enseignante en question l'état de
santé de l'enseignante de musique
n'inspire pas d'inquiétude selon la
préfecture les classes concernées
resteront fermées pendant 14 jours les
élèves pourront revenir à compter du 20
mars